tous les matins en nous réveillant je
pense plus je sauverai de gens
et plus je me ferais déni
et ce n'était qu'une question de temps
avant de rencontrer un qui soit trop
puissant
pour que je puisse le vaincre
je suis vraiment désolé du retard
j'ai eu un souci de circulation
problèmes de circulation ce serait pas
plutôt je sais pas avoir un type qui te
dirais tu à la mitraillette
oui oui ça bien sûr c'est à ça que je
faisais allusion
peter parker are you is born
je vais te montrer un truc qui va
intéresser au score tu te surveiller de
près pourquoi
c'est la question du jour dirais je sais
bien que tu ne me dit pas tout en paix
rappelle toi ce que tu dis il se crée
aucun prix tout comme la vérité mon nom
est richard parker j'ai découvert
comment au score allait exploiter mes
recherches
il est de ma responsabilité de protéger
le monde de ce qu'ils sont capables de
faire ça l'avenir
littéralement changé le monde et pour
peter tout le monde n'a pas une fin
heureuse
tu n'es pas de taille
j'ai fait un choix
c'est mon destin
tout le monde de 7 films
soir ce que c'est que de vivre dans un
monde
sans énergie
sans pitié
esso spider man